now there's a million different a
million on one different ways to set out
integration by parts okay I'm just going
to show you the way that I like and you
can sort of judge whether it's worth
keeping or not if you show me another
method and you think it's better not to
see it it's good to have lots of
different tools in your toolbox so you
can pick the one that best suits you
okay here's my integral okay now what I
want is to pick one of these as you and
one as d-v okay I'm going to select
which one as you will see in a second it
does matter which one you choose when we
were doing you know just regular chain
rule you can switch around no big deal
when you're integrating as you'll see it
makes a difference which one you select
okay so you select one as you just like
the other one as d-v okay so I think for
remembering let's have a look yeah I'm
gonna pick this term over here I'm gonna
make this one you and I'm gonna make
this one dB okay so here's the last time
I say u equals x right now I'm gonna
need all of these pieces eventually so
I'm going to use this box to help me to
go from to go from here to here I'm
gonna differentiate much like you
usually do with substitution okay
differentiate with respect to actually
get this one not too dramatic okay
in fact I specifically selected it so it
wasn't dramatic as you'll see when
something now I've got my new piece that
belongs here and here okay I've got my D
U piece as well which is here okay
because I can move that DX over and
displace it now what am I missing
I haven't put in DV yet so I'm gonna put
that over here so you can see on the
right hand side of my boxes okay these
are my derivatives you don't have to
write these it's just sort of my mental
framework okay they're my derivatives
and these are my are my primitives or my
integrals if you like okay so if I say
DV n DX I'm going to find that as
callers
so when you integrate you should get
back Vivi is the primitive isn't it okay
now again I'm gonna leave out all the
closest to the very end because I'm
going to integrate a couple of times
yeah what's the primitive cause it's
sign okay
so I've laid it all that all of these
are my pieces for doing this okay so
here's my this is my right-hand side the
integral of U DV okay so now what's on
the left-hand side I need U and V first
U and V okay so I'm gonna get X sine X
here okay then I subtract now integral
of I need the other pieces to V do you V
do you see what's going on once we get
sine X what's do you suppose if I put
one more step here you could say do you
equals DX you see how cross multiply
they're no big deal
okay so I'm integrating sign with
respect to X that's good I know how to
do that at home in a second you just
have a look what we started with right
how would you have done such a question
before because you have met questions
like this before
I'll tell you in a second we've reduced
it down to this right X sine X that's
just there okay what's the integral of
sine X
it's it's negative cause but I have an
egg if you don't I so plus coins and
that's all the integrations I'm done
with all the integrations so now I check
my constant on is it right how can you
tell let's just see what happens okay
let's differentiate X sine X plus cos x
and we're just not worry about the
constant cuz we know what happens to it
okay Duprat rule okay what are you gonna
get here you're gonna get sine x 1 plus
x cos x ya tributed cause negative sign
right so it works it works that's a
minor miracle now hold on a second I did
say to you before that you've met
questions like this you've been in
extension 1 but we don't just throw you
in the deep end like this
do you recognize them now we do things
like this we'd say part a differentiate
X sine X and then we'd say Part B hence
integrate X cos x because if you just
take this pot you know this is up sorry
this part differentiates than that and
this you there's my X cos x that I need
and you can work it out okay this is the
way we phrased and integration by parts
question to an extension one student who
doesn't know what integration by parts
is right so it's kind of like a watered
down integration by parts question but
now you can just look at it off the face
of the bat and just go for it ok so what
did I do
I looked at this and I had to select
these two pieces over here okay now I
trace them this way I arranged it I got
all my pieces together one of the
benefits of doing a greatests you know
that you've got all the bits and pieces
and then you can just substitute them in
I did save you before it matters which
one you choose for which so let's just
think about what happens if I chose the
other way
actually I'm doing like this I'll do
another box and suppose I chose cause X
as you okay so u equals cos X now from
here to here I'm differentiating so
what's the U on the X negative sign okay
so if that's you then my DV should be
the other factor in the product right so
DV on DX should be X right so well it's
my last piece and how do I get it my
last piece is V and I get it by
integrated no no right this is by the
way this is why having this box right it
shows you at your primitive computers
there well yeah you can still do it
wrong
um the integral of course is having
square okay now I wonder if you can see
yet why this is a bad choice okay when I
take all of these pieces and I go to
answer substitution this line what are
you gonna get okay well they UV that'll
be half cuz sorry half x squared cause
it's no big deal doesn't matter what
that is in some senses because I don't
have to do anything to it don't have to
integrate but then you get to this guy
this guy is the integral of VDU integral
of V du u you're gonna be integrating
negative 1/2 x squared sine X
integrating negative 1/2 x squared sine
X with respect to X this guy is not an
improvement this guy is worse than what
I started with see what's going on
so therefore how'd you articulate how
would you express why did you choose one
as you and the other one as DV how do
you pick what kind of quality are you
looking for
particularly in DV
how to articulate it you're looking for
something bad when you put together this
guy this guy when you put them together
you need something you'd know how to
integrate okay so when I put this guy
and this guy together cool I can
integrate that and that's what happened
here okay now it's not always
automatically do you get something
simple and nice like one in there you're
frequently get it but not always
okay but you want to think about that
combination okay because if the
combination can be integrated you'll be
fine
it gets at this step and you say okay
the value eight and a big deal okay but
you do need to choose carefully